they love the self-punishment huh yeah
Japanese are [__] gangsters that's
why I like them though yeah because they
also go I made a mistake see you later
[Music]
so real quick you guys heard about uh
what just happened in Japan live in
Japan by the way Tat's up
is it the Fukushima fish yeah baby
Fukushima water
so yeah China
says they're not gonna eat any fish
ordered from Japan they banned they ban
Seafood from Japan so the reason we're
just saying this is because Japan has
begun releasing fukushima's treated
radioactive water into the Pacific
prompting a strong rebuke from China
Anthony Lee was there when this happened
the day that I arrived was it the prime
minister or who was it the guy that was
like eight fish on camera like hey the
fish is cool though yeah he ate
radioactive fish he probably ate like
some fish that they got from someone and
it's like confirmed like proven that
that's the same they said that it's that
it's from there basically what they've
been doing since 2011 or whatnot is
they've been like taking that water and
they've been storing it in these like
giant tanks yeah but they just ran out
of real estate there's the water that
they flooded the plant with right yeah
so there's just no way they can hold any
more so now it's just kind of like it
just hit that kind of moment where it's
like okay there's nowhere else to put it
so we're gonna have to treat it or
release it into the ocean it's been
treated they've been treating it right
you know what's so stupid about Japanese
people is
um they could have totally just left it
out for evaporation but they had to
[__] dump it back in the ocean
because they're trying to make Godzilla
but if it's you're really trying to oh
they're gonna do it if they wanted to if
you leave it out for evaporation doesn't
that just do the same [__] isn't it
still radioactive rain yeah they'll just
make Mothra it goes in the clouds
[Laughter]
yeah
that was fast that was very fast yes
Godzilla universe that was good that was
really fast
um yeah so it's gonna happen over 17
days long
um they've been doing it now the whole
time and it's it's drawn protests in
Japan South Korea so I mean if they
don't got no space where is they
supposed to put it yeah what are the
protesters doing like that they're not
gonna do anything we're holding up signs
brainstorm or something did you hear
about the radioactive pigs what happened
to them oh yeah during the spill they
all of these uh pigs started eating up
like the radioactive plants and debris
and everything there yeah and then they
became like [__] radioactive monster
boars yeah and then they're asking
Japanese Hunters to just go and then
like kill them and then the hunters like
there's not we don't have enough guns
here so they're like anybody want to
come and kill some radioactive pigs come
along for real I wonder what they look
like crazy Japanese radioactive Pig do
they look any different they got like
tumors and stuff they supposed to be
like big ass [__] with crazy ass tusks
and they just look like like radioactive
so they're like rocks they look like the
yeah
holy [__] hell yeah I don't know if
Bebop was a rhinoceros or the pig I
don't know they look like Toco and razor
from the movie oh yeah
part of me kind of just trust the
Japanese they say it's good I think it's
all good no is that wrong for me I'm not
stupid they're infants
[Laughter]
but it just looks like a pig okay
what about sending the water to China I
like how honest you were without looking
up some freak wait what they look crazy
it does look like a kind of that does
look like a regular bore
can you can you just send it to China
only got some space yeah we should do a
collab do they have space it's like a
big hole and pour it in there or
something I don't know if their nations
are like cool like that right now they
should they should just get over it when
they're treating out they're just
pouring bleach in there what are they
doing they should go see a therapist
they should they should be baking soda
absorb it yeah that could be do they
have betterhelp.ch
I thought they already been dumping the
water and it's been going into the ocean
I bet they have who knows what they say
they haven't they say they've been
storing it and now
um everyone's freaking the [__] out
about it fishing groups are especially
affected especially just public
perception wise people are going like
what should I do I'm not gonna eat fish
is that a mess like insanely big Market
buying fish from Japan yeah even for
themselves right because they get they
fish throw their own fish but like the
exports too yeah yeah man and that's the
thing it's the it's also you know is it
going to destroy the the Ecology of the
region right we don't know what the
impact's gonna be yeah
so you show up this starts happening
what's the tenor and tone of the region
you're just kidding News live
corresponding you're on boots on the
ground you know what's crazy uh years
ago I was actually talking to a Japanese
dancer right who just had this like not
like it's overly pride of Japan feeling
but it's more like uh my country my
nation made this mistake so I will eat
the fish because I am the people of this
country whatever happens they love the
self-punishment huh Japanese are funny
that's why I like them though yeah
because they also thought I made a
mistake see you later yeah freaking
honor kind of dope man you know what
that guy's dad said she's like he didn't
do any
you didn't do it
Dad no we're people hella talking about
it there like were you nervous about
eating fish there uh no because like I
also maybe because I heard that and I
learned it and I kind of like respected
something about it I feel a similar
thing it's like at the end of the day
human beings did this like us as a
species we like [__] experimented
with [__] I didn't do anything dude
nature did it dude we didn't do [__] I
didn't do [__] don't replace yourself to
like a Somalian pirate you're like
they're just human beings that do things
so the way your brain goes you make
things evil for no reason it's only for
Anthony you said you said you sit human
beings there's honor in the in the code
of what I'm speaking and you're like
just dishonoring the honor part you're
you're taking L's for every with
everybody the honors you're taking a big
fat out with this water goes in the
Pacific you're already eating it I'm
just acknowledging it I'm not can I say
something dude I eat chicken of the sea
look are you chicken nuggets
don't give him that if you have a couple
pieces of nuclear Sashimi you'll be fine
dude diluted solo you'll be fine bro you
just don't eat it all the time you just
[__] you know you mix it in we eat a
little bit of mercury with it anyway oh
dude we got Plastics and everything
people are talking about micro plastic
got microplastics we got pesticides on
stuff like even the organic [__] yeah
but that's not the nuclear [__] you dumb
[__] Plastics like oh yeah we got we're
drinking out of plastics
they're like yeah it's not drinking
nuclear in 12 years from now they're
gonna be like oh Red Bull causes this
death blah they're talking about
fluoride in our tap water you know what
I mean I'm turning the frogs gay yeah
but then yeah that too which is actually
yeah
there's so many gays lowers your IQ gay
frogs makes you dumber apparently it's
supposed to be good for your teeth other
people are looking at us like why are
you drinking [__] milk from a cow
because it's bomb that's that's cool
that's fine but I'm just saying like no
matter what everything is already like
we're all a part of this [__]
ecosystem and we submit to it so I'm
like it is what it is if we're drinking
fluoride in the water it lowers our IQ
how are we smart enough to know that
[Music]
that is brilliant dude how are you not a
stoner what the [__] I kinda am
so are you saying like the the when it
gets dumped in the ocean it's gonna
reach every corner of the earth anyway
some through some means like Joe said I
think they've already been it's been
leaking for for over 10 years it's
already affected whatever Fukushima
happened Shores in California were
experiencing radiation yeah like it's
more it's over what we've been eating
radioactive [__] for as long as that's
happening and they're just released
by the way the ocean does have an
unbelievable whatever you call it you
know the way that the current filter
system it's pretty crazy how the ocean
can cycle out like waste yeah but it
does take a long time and you know we
got [__] tires in the ocean we got
trash in the ocean we got a giant
[__] plastic pool in the ocean yeah
we got a big [__] gigantic mud ball
of trash just let Gaia do its thing
just a big old Brita is that your nice
way of saying bucket let's just all eat
it Loki yeah all right you don't need to
eat it directly from the source I mean
like maybe we can just eat Pacific Cod
and then it's like far enough or like
Atlantic salmon or whatever you know
yeah there's no radiation in peanut
butter and jelly I say the Japanese
people just for a certain amount of time
peanut butter and PBS like a month just
for a month yeah just a cup of noodle
cup of noodles PB and J and some katsu
it's not radioactive I want to turn into
a toxic Crusader though when I eat it
have you ate one of those strawberry
cream sandwiches you could you gotta try
it when you're in Japan what is that so
they have like these fruit sandwiches
where they put fruit with cream and then
it's like a [__] white bread sandwich
oh my God you get it from a vending
machine it's like strawberry shortcake
are you going for like 7-Elevens and
Lawsons yeah
machines in Japan are Next Level that's
the last level that's the last level
that's like literally as good as it gets
yeah and and you can be like on a hike
to go check out a waterfall and there's
a vending machine and you're like who
put this [__] yeah and it's like you get
a wedding cake out of it in nature yeah
if we could find a way to do a little
bit of that in the states that'd be
pretty cool I don't even know how to do
that though it's [__] crazy yeah I
don't know how they do it and then the
vending machine will have hot and cold
drinks too sometimes yes it will that's
an amazing yeah what the [__] they got
vending machines that serve high balls
what's that whiskey and club soda but
it's like dude that's just out there
they just trust trust their people to be
like oh maybe the kids will drink yeah
the Japanese are efficient so I trust
them dude I trust their fish so if they
say they treated it they probably did
treat it then well dude yeah because the
Chinese said they treat I don't know
about that yeah Chinese don't treat
things very good sometimes because
they're non-treated things are already
Radioactive
I trust all the stuff I got from teamu
bro it is I trust them to clean it up we
always do when BP makes two cookies for
the Chinese isn't it like so Japanese
people be like oh no we made an accident
sorry it's a little bit of radioactive
but then Chinese people are like oh
here's a perfectly good natural fish
let's put some lead and radioactive and
let's get a little bit of more [__] and
now it's good yeah I gotta I got a fake
NFL jersey from China and they didn't
treat it very good I got fake Yeezys
from Tito
it's they fit great but they smell like
fish for some reason
it's radioactive fish I don't know what
the [__] I probably got here on a barge
that's why but it didn't it didn't smell
like fish when I first got him it's like
as the months went on I'm like oh oh
yeah open the soul up it's a scratch and
sniff
[Music]
foreign